yes I remember the days you should just
complain about youtubers making [__]
districts now I'm longing I'm longing
longing for those days when you're in
those days they feel terrible until you
realize Sam YouTube privilege is a [__]
[Music]
starting this true news we're going to
talk about the terrorist attack in New
Zealand were obviously sudden our
thoughts to the families the vit of the
victims it's absolutely awful you've
really gone into this so that you've
watched the footage and because the guy
was [__] was he live-streaming what
he was doing it was quite sad to watch
because you realise how many of the
people who are in these situations are
mentally ill people there's a lot of
people out there who say if a person is
from a certain country they're a
terrorist if they're a white person
they're mentally ill now we're not
giving them a [__] break at all if
you believe killing people is going to
get you into heaven you're probably
mentally ill armed terrorists as well
there is the other side to it where
these situations also bring the best of
humanity out in some people this woman
was one of the bystanders who stepped in
to help was on the other side he put
three people in his cat and his car and
took them to hospital and the guy on the
street he was trying to run his wife
other one I hate when the worst of
humanity comes out the best of humanity
also comes out in opposition to it and
that's it's the only silver lining to
these [__] horrible things when you
say you could people like her let me
read you a quote from one of the
senators in Australia who had some
interesting ideas speaking following
reports of multiple shootings at two
mosques in New Zealand earlier today
senator Fraser Anning was respond has
responded with strong condemnation good
aren't good on him you thinking yeah I'm
not expecting much else I'm utterly
opposed to any form of violence within
our community well done so far and I
totally condemn the actions of the
gunman he said you've condemned Dundas
Laurie was not that just move on that's
complete nice job to us job don't that's
the part on the roads job Fraser
learning however he goes on saying while
however with it however does not coming
this at any [__] point it's the same
as you know when someone comes to
apologize and they go I am sorry however
whilst this kind of violent
vigilantism is interesting to call it a
vigilante this is not vigilantism at all
you're not you're not running down the
street catching a robber you're going in
and shooting innocent people
yeah to death what it highlights is the
growing fear within our community both
in Australia and New Zealand of the
increasing Muslim presence as always
letting fear should be from that country
shooting people the fact that it's
harder to get a Ferrari than it is to
get a killing machine yeah it's just
wrong why your Ferrari is expensive when
they're just fun yeah and killing
machines cheap and easy to quiet yeah
Jeremy it should be the other way around
in my opinion yeah I want a Ferrari and
I want people to not be able to afford
things that can kill me absolutely can
we just so this guy were about to watch
is the guy who gave that quarter you
just said this yeah now he went on to
give a much longer quote which was just
more as he calls it nonsense I don't
condone what happens in this video Bryan
but it's hardly entertaining all the way
could this guy look any more Austrian
I'm shocked that stop Monday is just all
very sure that though this is my tragedy
but it's going to be eventually accepted
or expected that unbelievable he's a
commander coos yes mom this guy is
mental you elected in Queensland and
then watch right
what so this kid is then put into a
headlock by basically this guy's cronies
and he wasn't allowed up basically six
men went on top of this kid I'm not
condoning what the kid did although I
understood you wanna watch it one more
time go on well I love it most of us the
kid does this okay that Monday's
thinking the kid didn't give a football
did he really hit him didn't give a [__]
over this senator is what we want to
call in a [__] once again thought to go
out with the families it's awful and I
just hope it doesn't happen anymore not
the only person arrested lately mr.
Conor McGregor arrested again [__] me so
a guy was reportedly sort of harassing
column
Gregor outside of a nightclub at 5:00
a.m. videoing and he's just sigh I don't
[__] need this [__] right now you
know fix the phone off him and smashes
the phone that's other good shoulder Wow
yeah the guy shockingly his suing Conor
McGregor what for so what happened was
we seek McGregor in the club and it was
all cool on the way out we would just
wait for our vehicle from the valet so
we just wait for our vehicle to pick up
and then as soon as we caught because
Massey Conor McGregor so I'm yeah I
think I'm a little fall you can tell
when someone's lying when they add extra
words into a sentence I was trying to
take up my little phone yeah as if that
makes it any less harassing it pulled me
in and it grabbed my for all of us
smashing it always around he's one of
these guys who probably hangs around
nightclubs and places like that to get
footage of celebrities to use it against
them and like I seen that smashed a for
not a be honest I'm a bit annoyed at
McGregor the fact that he's having more
arrests than fight wins in the last
three years speaks volumes about the
state that his careers in right now
you're in the prime of your career right
now and your piss farting around in
nightclubs 24/7 and if that's what you
want to do fine
retire who dawn string the fans along in
that we're hoping that one day he's
gonna get in and put on a vintage
McGregor performance ago and I'm not
asking him to win but just go in there
and be the old Conor McGregor and
[__] go after someone and give it all
but I say I'm doing all this [__] and
the suits and the nights out and the
clubbing and all that I'm like yeah have
fun whatever but I just kind of look at
him more of a celebrity now than a UFC
fighter I'm also board of people
targeting big celebrities that's
pathetic
yeah James Charles showing that if
anyone puts makeup on their face
regularly enough you will have that kind
of skin do you not makeup skin what two
makeups good just that sort like that
shiny shiny sort of you know what I mean
this guy looks after himself
he needs to help me out with my beauty
regime yeah alright I won't see you go
through a transformation
lots of Mon it's not a dragon that is a
drag queen is they call there's good
writing balls
why ex-wives XY crumbs we are getting in
always saying XY chromosome you know
we're not saying XY chromosome we're
getting into XY or is that an xx that's
that's good I I like the band xx so drug
means you're a man who dresses up as a
woman no yeah that's not transgender so
I'm right in saying it tomorrow I
literally don't know who the [__] I'm
talking about yeah don't don't tell me
to do my research right [__] off I'm not
watching RuPaul's Drag Race I'm for one
shot this right I've got to watch an
hour
RuPaul if a woman walks in the room and
you went your beautiful radiant
fantastic amazing they go if I got
something on my face are you being
sarcastic but when a drag queen walks
into the room they people go amazing
fantastic keep walking
thank you amaze incredible if my
girlfriend walks into a room pair of
heels the first time I go oh you look
amazing most beautiful I don't then keep
going go go go go go go go one two three
four five you look fierce genuine with
these people begin you look that sure
it's beautiful right that's a really
pretty face I know the purpose of the
video is so that they look amazing like
you have to be overly done oh that's why
you can always tell it isn't an actual
woman no because what I want to see what
run down the [__] gauntlet yes son I
want to see you do one of these up to
make them look sort of casual because I
think it'd be more believable because I
don't I don't see women ever dress up
like I'd never keep in a woman out in my
life looking like that ribbon I want you
to put on a weave one day I didn't want
to see how you looked brave the battle
O'Brien slay slay you know yeah and
you're just say going and the rest of
them are going raw yeah boom and the
rest of them are going new how does he
flexes tits like that
that's [__] incredible oh my god slay
Brian slave
in order to appear in this society like
this at one point took incredible
bravery from something love affair play
but 21 minutes doesn't take that long
either that's what I'm wondering how
real women take hours to get ready these
[__] 20 minutes you'll I've got
some explaining to do they've sped up a
lot of this even this bit sped up look
they're so sorry I'll take that back you
[__] I have to be honest you were I
know they're men but they look better
than some women I've shot not saying I
hugged them because obviously they
probably wouldn't want nothing to do
with me exactly but then we're not we're
not going there at the same time for you
you said this the other day and you said
it over lunch holds her whole is what
you said to me I didn't say that yeah he
said I'll shove it anywhere nice and
then looked in the eye and said a
private conversation
I probably if she was a woman if she was
an actual woman on the right I probably
would bullet dryer translation with
plastic tiara Oh complete oh my god you
guys this is literally you're not
literal stop nobody you've got a penis
you know I mean why does it take your
people so much science I am I would well
you need somewhere for a fetus
suggesting you know I mean if you want
to be a woman you need I can't keep it
in a bag credit of them they look
fantastic
maybe maybe James child's would do
what's up one day there is enough fat
sort of speech right to be honest with
you for the amount of [__] views he
gets I've always thought I was pretty
other more people give me credit forward
it'd be good to finally prove you a lot
wrong you know people see the beard they
say sure he's a handsome man pretty
kinda man but I could be pretty anyway
yeah I could do all ninja got paid 1
million pound or dollars whatever hey by
dr. evil eye ear pecs legends to play
their game on a livestream on a brandy
so yeah ninja got offered a million
pounds to play this so Mendel is up just
to play a game that's amazing all I'm
saying is people need to stop giving
these youtubers too much [__] money
yeah the jaw
anyone out there watching this video
never approached us with a brand deal
I'll be absolutely clear I'll tell you
to [__] off if you ever try and give us
money
we're not sellouts like the rest of them
no there's your gaming community mean
nothing to you ninja yeah I used to
think I suspect you I used to respect
you before you started doing
King drinks and having a good time I'm
tricking the ear [__] me all your
money
pathetic I'm getting more views again
now I'm playing the cool game everyone
complete but I wanna play yeah [__]
zombies Oh ninja jumped off a bridge
would you do that would you
ah you [__] idiots in a game yeah
digitally would you digitally jump off a
bridge if he did digitally would you
would you shoot other people and try and
get number one in fortnight would you
seen this little guy on Twitter I loved
him and I think you're gonna love him
too you know something I've always said
to do with my entire life is people
feeling unnecessarily sorry for me just
because I'm in a wheelchair I didn't get
a choice this was just the way wife's
decided to [__] me so instead of
bitching and complaining I bent over
spread my cheeks and said go ahead have
a good time oh yeah genuinely I'm happy
you know if anything I feel sorry for
you guys
the able-body people I got to worry
about that I can eat whatever the [__]
that one I can do what other [__] I
wanted my body and it's not changing my
body is already [__] all right and you
guys had to work out everyday wake up at
the ass crack of dawn to go running oh
[__] that I feel sorry for you guys good
logic I do I like him I like his message
what he'd been dealt in life and just
spun it and just thought [__] I'm just
gonna roll with it you never quite a lot
of people never question those things
you know the fact that they go to the
gym and that kind of stuff they're not
quite and he's got another perspective
it's a good healthy outside those things
a point to learn from that is we've all
got [__] to deal with stop [__]
morning about it and just get out make
the best of what you've got and I like
that attitude I like when he said I
spread my ass cheeks I'm not and stars
very funny he's right good
I do appreciate any said you've made my
day [__] daddy yeah big up son
we know boxers aren't always the
brightest guys in society god I love
them but it's true amir khan here
further demonstrates that when he
explains Bruce Jenner becoming
what's-her-name and Caitlyn Haley
what's her name again nobody's shouting
X Y and the other one this no but that's
the thing is because I know for a fact
what Caitlyn Jenner's trying to do right
I didn't know about the other two right
which I mean to be honest with you
they're just dragged on this key
different yeah different I mean because
I didn't mean to call Caitlyn that was
you know happy watching it from the
Olympic Olympics when you won the gold
medal he was a hero and I'll get my fun
so obviously I remember in movie hour
where all the shock is a shocker shop
Kaelyn 130 his man's doing verbal
[__] twister right now god bless I
feel confused himself more than he's
confused anyone else
and I imagine Caitlyn gets that quite a
bit punch you know yeah I imagine
Caitlyn gets that a lot where someone
goes through Kate Caitlyn good see a
[__] yeah [__] daddy
I get the feeling that you and silvio
berlusconi have a lot in common however
have you ever murdered a Moroccan born
model can you explain who Berlusconi is
to be right because some people weren't
know so it's gonna use to be I think the
Prime Minister of Italy are the order
Football Club W the only football club
AC Milan he's known to be a bit of a bad
dude he's also known to be a pretty
extravagant and wild dude and he's
Italian allegedly he used to have bunga
bunga parties which are allegedly
massive alleged sex parties a little
yeah
however someone who's been basically a
witness in one of the cases against him
and mysteriously died in hospital with
radioactive poisoning whoa
normally the Russian there's not that
woman's yeah that's her she's pretty as
well right you feel sorry for she's more
pretty to do to give evidence yeah so
she was due to give evidence against
Silvio Berlusconi miraculously she told
her brother of her lawyer that she'd
been poisoned he isn't he's a bad guy
yeah what a [__] I know you get a bit of
beautiful women dying as
kind of death right Gambino crime family
not Childish Gambino boss Frank Cali
shot dead outside Staten Island home so
who the [__] daughter bright so the
Gambino crime family I to me was just
like an old thing that was in the movies
but I kind of thought that that sort of
stuff didn't happen anymore so that's
why I was sort of fascinated by FX
legends got in touch I don't want your
[__] money give it to ninja he was 53
shot several times and run over the
first mob boss to be slim in New York
see since John Gotti ordered the murder
of then Gambino boss Paul Castellano so
a mob hit comes as New York's
experienced a resurgence in mob activity
in recent months I didn't know carly was
a quiet real old-school boss support I'm
the boss of this family he was the boss
the boss at his family get him a nice
caprese salad huh I shouldn't have to
come to you yeah hat in my hand asking
you to provide for this family and do
your job buffalo mozzarella whose dad is
this baffle police confront dominatrix
dragging man and chain around busy
Waterloo station a stunned onlookers
share snaps on line rifle video I don't
want to watch the full video right I'm
gonna let go
the police are asking what the [__] is
going on cuz she's got a man via [__]
chain around his neck so say not
technically illegal but it isn't and
they couldn't do anything about it
yeah I've taken your kids out for the
day and you're like oh well just go for
a little stroll around London you're
just literally watching quite a tall
thick black woman this silly old man and
quite a thick silly white guy on his
knees yeah ain't drug run by a chimp
this man's getting his rocks off he's
loving this he's gonna be coming to this
off oh yeah remember that time when
you're out in public
oh yeah Gary look at her smiling out on
probation for Miss socks
her business is going to go through the
[__] roof through it all the way
through it probably like walk to there
was a public walk one but it was in a
less popular station pop you can in
street record it in such a way is
amazing for me it's so we can watch it
back miss Fox you're welcome on the
podcast anytime and I just say I make a
great pot I was yes to be a good podcast
as a poet yeah you have a point however
I'd be worried that she would sort of
boss the conversation and we'd be sort
of going yeah we already had to do that
by the end of it she's got a chain
around your neck she's walking you on
your hands and knees semi down between
your legs I want that but then maybe I
would who knows there's anyone we find
out Brian with your body roof you refer
to it as a public a [__] walk what
society come to when this is getting
millions of views Brian filling my
boyfriend with choose yeah yeah my god
look at the dock oh my god she's sort of
already killing him with cheese and
other food ages you know your your
life's at a real low when your dogs
using you as a pillow when I see people
like that I don't think Oh disgusting I
hate you are you sure yeah I think I
want to try and get you help
do you I think I just wonder how much
this sweat and things like that little
things yeah a little things the details
how the belly rolls over and sits on top
of that pelvis sake will there be a lot
of like be all in between those cracks I
don't know that's what I would this is
what I call a close call oh god are
these [__] me up these sort of shirts
ready here here he's still walking keep
walking old man oh my god this man
dodged death by
just a couple of seconds suppose all of
us feel lucky today that we've dodged
death if you're ever walking under
scaffolding or buildings and so forth
this probably why you should cross the
road and [__] like here's the thing that
was actually just a gust of wind on a
normal wall yeah so what we really
should be saying is Theresa May really
can you do something about the wind down
the wind up the money like I said
earlier for Rory's not guns yeah now
Brian I know that you're well into sort
of pulling women yeah that would you
like to do where you going with us just
shut up and answer
I'm not answering [__] until you tell me
where the [__] you'll burn and
manipulate my words this guy is gonna
show you a new technique to get women
can I just say I was being ironic he's
not he's going to show you the opposite
of technique it's there yeah
chop it up quite literally doesn't it'll
make you fat if you eat too much of it
this is one of the biggest cuts I've
ever seen in my life mmm but I want to
keep hating him and watching him well if
people do have sex with you yeah lucky
oh yes he makes ice cream for a [__]
living whoa you've crossed a line there
Brian people who make ice cream are good
people
this guy is making pan and ice it's the
eye contact wait for the eye contact
here's tip number one for you Brian
watch watch it a master at work oh yeah
[Music]
to be absolutely he's doing like a
Chippendale does we're maid you know and
they do it
mm-hmm I hate it I [__] hate him I
hate it what you smiling for I want him
to die no I don't wanna die person the
flames you've got I've never seen
someone love themselves that much doing
customer services yeah work on the tills
before I [__] here in my life I hated
it like any other self-respecting person
does when they do that job imagine him
as dead we've all been there
no I was at Morrison's [__] like that
when I was scanning sort of vegetables
and groceries or through the [__]
till for your middle-aged woman getting
a shop in area I don't go mmm
so he what are you doing tonight you
gonna go home and have a little bit oh
yeah I definitely at no point did I say
detergent makes you sexy no I didn't
[__] do that
cabbage makes you sexy guys absolute
[__] Mia Khalifa is engaged I know
you're gonna be happy well done son you
wiped up the [__] whoa hold on there she
was only a porn star for three months
trying now Brian I have a video to show
you do you know in the mid to late 80s
early 90s early 2000s there was a
restaurant called Hooters everything
anymore cuz I was kind of hot when we
went to America we could go this those
who don't know who the girls are they
don't wear a lot when they're serving
you and they've all got like big tits
who just had an airline Brian it was 100
no 129 dollars to fly one way hundred
twenty-nine dollars to fly one of these
girls flying the plane that would be my
first movie like oh how strict is the
policy yeah here's the thing I think we
disappoint most people is when you then
got on the flight it was a normal flight
with just two Hooters girls on it look
at that kid's face look at his best life
he's like what feel going on can I just
say as well how many wives that there
will be comfortable they get weight you
flying to today honey go enough to
Charlotte off to a little conference
down there and Charlotte what you flying
on Hooters air see you later honey sorry
I thought you said who does there there
honey yeah I gotta get down the airport
Susan these men are going away to
Hooters and etc etc just looking at
women's boobs do you feel comfortable
with that
when men are on
this doesn't matter what the women are
wearing their men if the women are
good-looking we're gonna get checked out
anyway
so they might as well dress up a few if
you ever heard stories of Wilt
Chamberlain you know the basketball
player I was reading excerpts from his
autobiography earlier this week not in a
toilet just in his seat instead of
stopping her he just went can I get a
blanket please and just put the blanket
over her as well Chamberlain for you
everyone I genuinely will never forget
on the flight I think over to or from
Italy yeah there was a woman when we did
the ultimate football holiday that you
really huge oz she was so fit right blue
van
man we go there is here he is now number
one thing we need to know here he is a
Leicester City fan people have been
certainly what a month at kickoff I'd
quite like him on the kickoff but
doesn't even cut this dark out Larry to
refer he's got the same mentors will
Ernie right right right
I'm gonna start repeating yourself it's
not now because I just do I do I'll
repeat yourself you know and I repeat
yourself that much sometimes I just
don't even know if I've said it the
first time I just repeat it
I'm just so that people actually now
have said it so I'm repeating you sex so
I've got this tendency to repeat the
supper you see that these repeating
things clean after these videos but
sometimes all these lines in the Bayer
as now you've probably seen this video
some repeating yourself names so me time
myself nine time yeah and I love his
lying his little jokes like that great
summers coming
it's the end of February right we've had
some real nice hot weather and you've
got people walking around in shorts I
went to the bloody Lester game I stopped
these blokes walking around in short
it's February my mother god rest her
soul used to say don't cast account out
till maze out what's a cloud sort of a
social medium and you got a lot of
followers and numbers is cloud yeah your
mother was very far ahead of her time
was shot with cloud guns yes in the
nursing home in Reza oh we've got a
little cloud gang over here haven't we I
suppose we deserve more puddings with
palliative cloud can always thought a
client was a clot
back of the end where you'd like been
putting stuff in the video recorder
video recorders might be a lot you out
there but the bloody house of video
recorder at least like a DVD player so
vo ye be say it was a DVD player doesn't
explain it just moves on what's what's a
video recorder well it's like a DVD
player
what's a DVD player well so it's
striking Scottish dairy ice cream
honeycomb may be the finest ingredients
once again I caught the only using the
finest ingredients they never crossed a
rooster named I have a honeycomb flavor
has got honeycomb in it and there's no
only cone in it it keeps flicking off so
between honeycomb and honeycomb and that
really gets to me the honeycomb taste it
the honeycombs coming through now it's
coming through that I don't even know if
that was a human noise that was my
session yeah please do go and subscribe
to blue van man he is a blue van man
apparently we've all been a suitable
that has not worked out to the lately
you would have thought just pressing
delete would delete stuff but no he
hasn't somehow God is somewhat else so I
can't be asked at the moment I've got
other things to do other things already
vote how the [__] do you work at in open
up yeah you know I'll start with the tit
opener then I'll work I hope you use the
[__] thing I record my videos it's
like man working out fire what people do
is to get the tin over and the points at
the side of the tent and turn the handle
will know we should be pointing the tin
opener on the top and turning it that
way I don't know how to
just came to Illinois I imagine him and
his wife laying in bed and he just sits
dead up it just goes off how can L know
he goes Frank Frank go to sleep he's
tossing and turning
is that a current safe and she's like
the ten openers and that was it we've
been using the wrong anyway one tonight
now wanted in tomatoes a tin-opener that
used to be my grandmother's granny grow
Gert she was about 95 I think I don't
know she's got that many years he's on
screwed
how the hell she made it that far I do
not know what a mysterious little woman
I want to know more about there's a
woman we have to get him on as a podcast
guest I feel like you'd be amazing he'd
be amazing on the kickoff I can't
believe that we've cooked on a tin I
love the fat but there was a bit of a
squabble over the inheritance yeah and
all the other kids are like how much did
she have 100 grand yet we'll split that
between the four of us yeah is that you
know you get your 25 grand just want the
tin opener side like normal folks do you
get the tin opener and you put it on the
top like so
and squeeze and it has taken a bite so
now you just turn it turn it and turn it
and turn it and guess what folks you
turn it and turn it until it's done
perhaps we all have been using the tin
opener the wrong way amazing I think we
leave it at that I could watch this guy
over there here's a phenomenon on
YouTube
blue van man wow what a guy I just
thought I want him to be on the kickoff
we'll work on it doing a great job
enjoyed it I mean it's obviously we had
was sad start away but hopefully you've
enjoyed the show and I hope people took
this week in the right
Tony's very difficult to shift between
very sad yeah we have a laugh we do feel
like it's important to mock everything
that's going on yeah even when we don't
really want to bring the mood down you
know you got it you've got to cover the
stuff up people want to know about our
thoughts so we've there obviously anyone
who is affected by that you guys are
okay this is it don't forget to like the
video if you have enjoyed it we're on
iTunes and Spotify Spotify are actually
using this to advertise Spotify it's a
subscription service we're not seen any
other money out of it we'll figure
Spotify show us the money [__] don't
forget to like the video subscribe say
is there